[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
do you remember sarah palin
[Music]
good god that was 14 years ago
that she was putting lipsticks on pigs
remember that holy [ __ ]
almost forgot who the [ __ ] she was
i almost completely forgot i mean until
she lost
another loss
oh so much losing so much losing
what a great week for america what a
great week for america and for democracy
really all around the world
oh sarah palin gets slam dunked in the
trash once again
by ranked choice voting here's here's
how you know
that there's some validity in
considering ranked choice voting
when sarah palin loses her race in
alaska
because of ranked choice voting that's
what they think it's because of ranked
choice voting that she lost they
couldn't rig it up
when the fascists are out
in the open going rank choice voting
should be banned
you know ranked choice voting is
probably has some valid reasons why we
should institute it all across the
country and states counties local
governments the federal government
i think i think it's not a bad idea
if they're if the fascists are going we
need to ban rank choice voting because
we'll lose i forget who it was someone
tweeted and we'll look at it later
said that now now republicans don't like
ranked choice voting i'm like they don't
like voting
this is not gonna go well for them in
rovember november is trending
you know might as touches saw in the
rovember shirts row row row your vote
the blue wave is coming folks and it's
gonna crash down on these [ __ ] morons
the evidence is clear that you
the people
are [ __ ] sick and tired of trumpers
and trumpism telling you what the [ __ ]
you can and can't do
america is sick of that [ __ ]
they're sick and tired of it they don't
want to hear it anymore
about how you you want to tell us what
[ __ ] religion we have to be who you
can can't [ __ ] love
what you can and can't do about your
[ __ ] medical decisions in your body
telling you
they're up a [ __ ] creek without a paddle
here
because they chose trumpism
as their principle
that's it they have no principles
they ran someone like sarah palin in
alaska that was their best bet
i don't know if you remember all the way
back to 2008.
but if you remember
when she came on the stage as john
mccain's running mate she was a
superstar she's a superstar the entire
country loved her because she was that
all shucks lady
from alaska she was the governor she was
an executive
she had experience
and soon we found out that she was a
[ __ ] idiot
and that she made
her run with john mccain as her stage
to stardom
hell she even abandoned a lot of her
principles that she had as governor
and mayor of what the hell's the town
gold
she was a mayor you know that was that
was the big thing she's a mayor
she was a mayor remember when mayor pete
ran they're like oh he's just a [ __ ]
mirror what does he know
say [ __ ]
say [ __ ] they still say that
[ __ ] about pete budaj
what does he know about transportation
he's just a goddamn mayor when sarah
palin ran in 2008 she like oh she she
would make a great president if john
mccain died because she's a mayor and
mayors make good president you remember
that
i'm trying to refresh your memory
this [ __ ] buffoon
because really sarah palin made way for
even bigger boneheads like lauren bobert
and marjorie taylor green
to hold [ __ ] office in this country
made way for it paved the way oh how
great of her to pave the way for fascist
like lauren bobert and marjory taylor
green thank you sarah palin we
appreciate it
if you remember she ran with john mccain
and she was a superstar for about five
minutes
until katie couric asked her what she
read and she was like i read everything
i read all of it all the newspapers
every single book all of them can you
give me example well just you name one
and i've read it
and it was a gotcha question remember
and the gotcha question
and then she went around the country
while john mccain was
trying to tamp down a lot of this barack
obama is a secret muslim and birth
certificate [ __ ] and all this nonsense
he was trying to tamp it down she went
around and went
leaned into the racism lean full into it
i remember she came here to missouri and
leaned into racism
they weren't letting her do interviews
they let her do rallies because she'd
get these racists all riled up in these
rural areas that's where she would go
she was trump before trump was trump
that's what it was
she was the original buffoon
then she went on [ __ ] fox news and
was a contributor there because she quit
as governor because
that's what these trumpers do is they're
quitters they're losers they're [ __ ]
losers they don't work for the people
they don't work for policy they don't
work to make government better they
don't work to to increase and progress
equality and equity
for the people they don't have the
people in mind to have themselves in
mind
and when she could go sell a book and be
a contributor for fox news and make a
hell of a lot more money than being the
stupid governor of alaska because that's
how she looked at it
she [ __ ] quit
she abandoned
alaska
as the governor she's like ah it's just
too much too much work for not enough
money i can go make money
being the head buffoon of the republican
party and she really thought she had a
great chance
she really did
she really thought she had a great
chance just like lauren bober and margie
taylor green think they have a great
chance
in the decades to come for politics
and yesterday
we find out that alaska
told sarah palin
to go [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off
[ __ ] off you
we done dealt with you we done dealt
with the trumpism and that's the best
part is trump went to alaska to endorse
this [ __ ]
hell they've stood on stage several
times together
they're kind of one and the same aren't
they
really honestly
sarah palin paved the way for trump
trump paved the way for [ __ ] idiots
like
marjorie taylor greene lauren bobert met
gatz jim jordan for these people have
voices
not only are they elected officials they
ask people these [ __ ] morons actually
listen
to this dribble
which only made way for the ron
desantis's
the greg abbotts
of the world
and now
now they're running [ __ ] like
herschel walker dr oz
are you are you [ __ ] serious
the republican party is in shambles
folks
they're crumbling
the foundation is gone
there is no foundation of the republican
party anymore think about this sarah
palin was the vice presidential running
mate with john mccain in 2008 she was
the rising star
she couldn't even win in a rank choice
vote
for congress
this is bigger than new york's 19th i
believe
no one knew who pat ryan was everyone
know who sarah palin is not a
[ __ ] in alaska doesn't know who
sarah palin is not a [ __ ]
not a [ __ ]
they know exactly who she is
and they said um no
nope not gonna happen not here
think about that
all you have to do is
oh we the people
but you the people
all you have to do
is lean into it
just [ __ ] lean into it baby
[ __ ] them the hell with them i don't
give a [ __ ] what they say about us i
don't care what they say oh we're gonna
politicize it because tonight you're
gonna hear a bunch of that [ __ ] you're
gonna hear all kinds of [ __ ] social
media is just gonna be rampant with
[ __ ] russian trolls and magabots
oh joe baden's politicizing this joe
biden's not making a policy speech he's
spending our money to run a campaign
blah blah blah but [ __ ] bloody blair
[ __ ] them
lean into it that's what biden's doing
democrats have finally found out the
white house has finally found out that
hey we're we're with you on the whole
getting rid of fascism thing we're with
you on that
we don't want them to [ __ ] have power
to take our [ __ ] rights away we don't
want that
the white house is woke
i guess you could say they woke up and
realized oh if we just lean into it
lean into democracy here
the american people are with us on this
thing
i mean they can disagree on exactly what
the [ __ ] student debt policy is
what the inflation reduction reduction
act actually had the the infrastructure
bill the buildback better bill would
[ __ ] the bed
covered relief we can disagree on those
things but there's one goddamn thing the
people in this country are going to
agree on
and that is to to absolutely chop up
trumpism
kill it [ __ ] it get rid of it it's no
good
it's fascism it's america first nazism
this idea that you could come in take
over the government get rid of books
tell us we can't learn math
tell us what truth and lies are when you
wouldn't know a [ __ ] lie if it sat on
your goddamn face and shook a little bit
tell us we can't do gun reform when we
know we can
tell us there's no way to do college
reform there's no way the american
people can get a hand up no way can we
do something about a decent [ __ ] wage
in this country no way can we make sure
that people don't go bankrupt because of
a health care and a medical bill no way
they we don't
the american people do not believe it
trust it trust in democracy i'm telling
you just lean into the [ __ ]
do what democracies do democracy
the people are telling you through the
vote because that's the real
problem that trump and his allies have
here other than he's going to go to
prison
for espionage and mishandling classified
top secret documents that too
and it seems like the january 6
indictments are ramping up kelly surreal
another oath keeper the oath keeper's
founder's girlfriend at the time when he
was indicted during january 6 not only
is she indicted on conspiracy like the
other keepers she's indicted on
obstruction of justice charges for
tampering yeah she's [ __ ] completely
[ __ ] she's probably going to be start
yelling and screaming here really soon
telling on these [ __ ]
we'll get into that hopefully later on
in the in in the show
but that's heating up genie thomas this
morning jeannie thomas
the big lie
the big lie perpetrator there's more
news about her so that is ramping up
but folks
we have to trust in our democracy we
have trust in each other it's us the
people
we're all on the same damn page as
democracy i mean there's a there's a
small percentage of boneheads out there
that don't understand about what
democracy is and what it delivers they
don't get it
but that's okay they're a small
percentage
we
can do it on our own we do not need them
and it is clear now
that this november will be the first
national election
where we get to tell trumpism
to go [ __ ] itself
that's what we get to do we have not had
one of those yet
we had hints of them right we've had
hints of them there's a few elections
last year
before the january 6 select committee
actually laid out the facts for the
american people
we've had a few special elections they
haven't gone trump's way
it's definitely not going his way for
the narrative for the secret secret
documents that he stole and didn't keep
secure
and broke laws
and committed crime around those
documents
it's not going well
it's not going well
for trump and trump allies and trumpism
in general in this country the american
first
fascist the manga republicans the nazis
are on the run
and they're losing everywhere
think about the possibility because this
nonsense that that the democrats aren't
going to keep the house as [ __ ] dumb
it's [ __ ] dumb
it's dumb it's [ __ ] dumb what what
what a dumb [ __ ] thing to predict
that the republicans are going to win
the house get the [ __ ] out of here
if you you are not paying attention to
what happened in new york's 19th in
alaska last night you're not paying
attention and you didn't pay attention
to kansas
people do not
want their [ __ ] rights taken away
from them
they don't want to be told what religion
to have
and not to have they don't want to be
told what they can and can't read
they don't want to [ __ ] have books
banned
they don't want the government in their
[ __ ] lives telling them who they can
be who they can love who they can [ __ ]
and how they can [ __ ] them they don't
want it
american people don't put up with that
[ __ ]
regardless of their ideology there are
plenty of folks out there that have no
idea what a republicans no [ __ ] clue
what a democrat is no idea they don't
know what a moderate independent is they
have no [ __ ] clue they probably don't
even know who the vice president of the
united states is
but there's one goddamn thing they know
you are not
you are not going to tell me what i'm
going to do in my [ __ ] in my life
that's one thing you're not gonna do oh
it's the republicans who are telling
people do that i don't know what the
[ __ ] a republican is but i'm not that
i'm not that
i'm not gonna let them tell me what the
[ __ ] to do
telling you it's really simple the only
thing you have to do the only thing we
as the people and the government because
we are the [ __ ] government the only
thing we have to do is go out and spread
this message
and tell people hey do you like do you
like a political party telling you what
the [ __ ] to do
who to love who to marry what to
identify as what clothes you can wear
what color you can dye your [ __ ] hair
what books your kids can read
rather you can get a [ __ ] medical
procedure to save your life or not nope
i don't like that who's doing that
republicans are doing all that [ __ ] well
i don't like republicans then that's all
you gotta do that's all you gotta do
that's it that's [ __ ] it that's all
you got to do
it ain't that hard you just get out in
the community and talk about it jesus
christ you see fetterman doing it you
see better doing it and it's [ __ ]
working it's [ __ ] working beto is
running around texas going to community
meetings he's not having big ass rallies
where they're throwing t-shirts with a
t-shirt cannon into the crowd and acting
like a [ __ ] fool he's going and he's
talking to people in their communities
about the problems that they have in
their communities and the problem that
they have is greg abbott telling them
what the [ __ ] they can and can't do
it's simple it's not complicated
so lean into it politicize the ever
loving [ __ ] out of everything
all of it
guns health care
abortion lean into it [ __ ] them
i'm telling you the american people do
not want someone telling them what the
[ __ ] to do they don't they won't
so all you got to do is convince people
to get registered to vote and to go vote
against the party that's right go vote
against
the party not for something against
something yeah that's right that's how
it works in politics unfortunately
that's just how it works
people vote against [ __ ]
not for it
that's where they [ __ ] up in kansas
they tried to rig the [ __ ] referendum
in kansas where the state legislator
would be able to tell women that they
don't have the right to their body and
their autonomy of their body they tried
to rig to vote make it confusing but
what they didn't think about is that the
vote was no
no no you're not gonna take our rights
away from us literally they went and
voted no
for them not to take their rights away
they didn't think about that people vote
against [ __ ]
and i'm telling you you're engaged in
politics you're here you're listening to
me every [ __ ] day you know this [ __ ]
you know what the hell's going on i show
you every day what the hell is going on
you think your neighbor knows they don't
[ __ ] know they got lives they got
[ __ ] they're doing they don't pay
attention to politics nor do they want
to
they again again
unfortunately in this country there are
a lot of people and it's called the
generic ballot a lot of people don't
know what the [ __ ] a republican is don't
know what the [ __ ] a democrat is no clue
no idea couldn't give a [ __ ] less either
but they they'll vote
especially
they'll vote especially if you tell them
what the [ __ ] republicans are trying
to do to their lifestyle
are trying to do that to to the [ __ ]
country
and what they want to do to american
people
you tell them that you [ __ ] you go
out and spread that message it's not
hard it's not a political message
i mean it's not like oh well we want to
raise the minimum wage to x amount of
dollars that's nope not a line item
not a line item don't go talk that [ __ ]
don't go be talking about line items and
bills that don't exist
don't be doing that
you just give them the cold hard facts
they want they're banning book fairs in
[ __ ] florida
they're trying to make sure that little
girls are carrying babies to full term
because they're not mature enough to
know if if they can get an abortion or
not
they're killing women in texas
because they're making them carry a dead
fetus inside their body
because they got religion and [ __ ]
get
the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ]
you really don't believe that this
message is on our side look what
happened in new york's 19th look what
happened in alaska look what happened in
kansas i don't know what more proof i
have to give you
i've been saying it for [ __ ] months
and months and months i've been yelling
into this microphone look people trust
it trust it trust democracy it's there
you just gotta [ __ ] lean into it and
really give it a go
really give it a good [ __ ] go
they're gonna lose they're on the run
jesus christ their orange deity
is on fraud social
admitting to crime admitting to it out
in the open
yeah you goddamn right you goddamn right
i did
did you did you steal those documents
you goddamn right i did
that's basically what he's doing
on his front social whatever the hell
that is that failing [ __ ] social
media [ __ ] over there
that son of a [ __ ] doesn't even load
worth the [ __ ]
it doesn't even load worth the [ __ ]
i'm over there i try to pull the stuff
and put it on twitter so you guys can
see this guy freaking the [ __ ] out and
was like stop posting his stuff what are
you talking about i'm not posting all
his [ __ ] i'm posting a [ __ ] that's
newsworthy like hey look what dude's
doing
what the [ __ ] this guy's doing this
guy's lost his goddamn mind
his marbles had packed their [ __ ] and
left
let's go harold we're getting the [ __ ]
out of here this guy's lost his mind
they i'm telling you you just gotta lean
into democracy here they're on the run
they're [ __ ] and
the best part is that you're going to
have the leader of the party who is for
democracy
the head of the party that is the only
party that is for democracy
this evening he's gonna come out and
he's gonna tell you
what i'm telling you right now i mean
he's gonna say it in a little more you
know what saucy language
but what the [ __ ] i yeah i don't care
what the [ __ ] do i care i'm just a
hillbilly from missouri
but joe biden the president united
states is gonna come out tonight and
he's gonna tell you what i've been
telling you for months
he's gonna say it out loud
he's gonna give the country permission
to make trumpism go crawl back
underneath this [ __ ] rock
it's enough of this fascist nazi [ __ ]
enough of it we don't want it
and he's gonna give you permission to be
on his side
regardless if you don't like this policy
or that policy or what he did here or
what he didn't do there he's gonna give
you permission to be on the side of
democracy
that's what he's gonna do he's gonna big
tent it tonight i have a feeling we're
gonna cover it on midas touch network i
actually put the link down in the
description
so when you're done with the broadcast
here make sure to go to the youtube link
down below for the president biden's
speech we're going to carry it tonight
it's going to be a special episode
of the midas touch podcast we're going
to guest host with the mizellas brothers
on the midas touch podcast it's at their
same time so we're just gonna
do that speech as their podcast that's
what we're gonna do so the link is down
in the description
so when the broadcast is over here don't
forget to go to that link and set your
reminder because you are going to want
to watch dark brandon
hand trumpism their [ __ ] ass tonight
because he is going to give the entire
country
permission to be on the side of
democracy tonight
that's what he's going to do
and the timing couldn't be better
the timing could not be better
and the reason why is because not only
are they losing in these races they're
[ __ ] losing
absolutely [ __ ] losing
alaska new york 19th kansas
beto's pulling ahead
herschel walker is getting absolutely
trounced oz he doesn't even exist other
than in new jersey
jd vance is barely a blip on the map
mark kelly is absolutely destroying
blake master so much so that blake
masters is for abortion now
[ __ ] idiot
they're on the run
they're on the run all you have to do is
trust democracy that's all you got to do
and i know you do you're here you're
listening to me even the [ __ ] trolls
here listening to me eventually will
believe in democracy trust me trust me
on this i know they're in the chat right
now they're saying dumb stupid [ __ ] they
seem [ __ ] stupid they're not they
seem delusional they're they're they're
saying all kinds of crazy ass [ __ ]
they'll get there
they'll get there soon enough they'll
learn the truth they'll learn they're
being brainwashed by their [ __ ]
facebook algorithm and their uncle earl
and aunt edna on facebook
but they'll they'll get there i promise
you this
you just have to trust it
that's what joe biden's gonna do tonight
is give you permission to trust his
party with democracy
because they're the only ones that are
[ __ ] interested in it jesus christ
the entirety of the [ __ ] republican
party's like yeah them pictures were
staged the fbi put them documents on the
floor to take a pic yeah no [ __ ]
sherlock
they were i i believe they were stuffed
in between those [ __ ] time magazine
frames that was his idea of security
right
come on you don't think
you don't think he
come on
that's what he thought he's like oh i'll
stick him between these time magazine
picture frame no i'll find them there oh
god they'll be looking all over the
place they'll be going to melania's
underwear drawer where i keep the
nuclear secrets but they won't find
these here
and then the three documents that he had
in his desk
he had kyle ridden house in that [ __ ]
room
bragging to him talking to him you don't
think kyle rittenhouse got a chance to
take a glance at top secret information
as trump stroked kyle
written house's little stupid [ __ ]
crybaby ego
so he could get that one thumbs up
picture where it spread around and he'd
get oh he likes kyle oh well i'm i'm a
domestic terrorist and i like kyle so i
must like trump
he knew that would get the domestic
terrorist support for him
in the same he was kyle rittenhouse was
in the same [ __ ] room
as those classified documents in the
desk drawer do you know why he has him
in the desk drawer it's really simple
it's really simple the reason why the
guy's got the [ __ ] [ __ ] in the desk
drawer
is so he can open up the drawer and brag
about it to whoever is in the [ __ ]
room his attorney even said it hey yeah
there's a lot of people go in that room
oh a lot of people there's a lot of
people that go in that room he's got a
lot of visitors that he shows classified
information to
hell hell if you give him four four or
five thousand dollars he just might show
you two of them
stupid [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ]
and this is where it's headed
and this is all his doing
this is all his doing and they [ __ ]
they chained themselves to trump
they chained themselves to trumpism and
stupidity and buffoonery
oh the fbi took a picture of the
documents that i stole
that they you know what those documents
that i stole i didn't have them laying
out on the floor like that jesus when
you steal documents you try to you know
organize them a little bit
what a [ __ ] idiot
but this is it folks you can lean into
it you can do this
i know we can save democracy if we just
trust it
and we fight for it because there's only
one party that's interested in it joe
biden's going to show you that tonight
he's gonna lay it out for you i i think
that's what he's gonna say
so join us tonight
tonight
as joe biden lays out why there's only
one party interested in democracy and
that is the choice you need to make is
for democracy
you need to support the pro-democracy
candidate the pro-democracy party hell
support pro-democracy speech not just us
not just this show if i mean if you want
to support this show the link is down
below
support.tonymichaelspod.com or you can
use the qr code
any any anything is appreciated here
but support every and that's not just
about money spread the message spread
the word shell share this podcast with
your friends and your family even the
ones that love trump have them come over
we'll get them in the trolls in the chat
and maybe we'll turn them maybe we'll
turn them they'll understand what the
[ __ ] they're doing and the delusion that
they're believing
it's really simple
we got this folks we got this we just
have to trust it that's all we have to
do so tonight
come join us on the minus touch networks
youtube channel the link is in the
description when you're done watching
the show today don't worry it's right
down there you can go to that link go to
it set your reminder after the show's
over the link is right there you can go
right to the video it's down in the
description when the show is over that
way you can go
and set your reminder for tonight
because you're not going to want to miss
tonight we're going to have coverage
it's a special edition of the midas
touch podcast me and gabe are going to
be guest hosting
with the mizellas brothers bringing you
live coverage of joe biden's speech
on democracy or fascism what do you want
what's the soul of the nation what are
we going to do here
we're going to talk about pardons here
in just a little bit on the [ __ ] list
roundup so it might be appropriate let's
go to a break the pardon blanket coming
right at you
right after this break stick around
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
we'll be right back
mark 60 seconds this is the tony
michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product
pardon blanket i've got you covered part
in blanket specifically works to make
you feel safe and cozy after your
involvement on january 6th and if you're
one of the other members of congress who
also helped with the attempted coup
pardon blanket will protect you too
pardon blanket is made of a sort of soft
fleece and a layer of sheep's wool and
they're 100 made in the usa don't delay
and get your pardon blanket today for
just 99.99
actual parting's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
trump is uh trying to pass out pardon
blankets
we're gonna watch a clip
he's trying to save himself he's trying
to get more support from the domestic
terrorists all around the country the
january
got some news on january 6 in the
insurrection and how they tried to steal
our democracy jeannie thomas back in the
news kelly surreal
kelly surreal gabe kelly surreal we know
that name don't we we do we know that
name pretty well
right um we've interviewed um we've
become really good friends with dakota
and tasha adams
von adams
uh stuart rhodes is a strange wife and
strange son right i'm pretty good
friends they're friends of the show here
the audience loves them because they
give great insight are you adjusting
your light [ __ ] what i did i'm trying to
get the i'm trying to get the color
right like it my camera
yeah he was trying to [ __ ] with it the
other day okay i think this is good you
look it looks great it's the the light
it but also like it's the camera auto
adjusting the balance well when you get
closer the light changes you know
someone someone was saying in the chat
if i go here yeah that's the way that i
look like leonardo dicaprio i don't know
if that's true you said that i don't
know someone was in the chat saying that
i saw that earlier
someone smoked that out whoever whoever
are you are you a little young i'm not
no i'm not i'm not i'm not no
what are you talking about oh you know i
went to karaoke yeah you went to karaoke
last night
right no i'm not hungover i'm not on
okay i'm just making sure you know i
don't know where you got that who says
you look at leaner i don't if someone
said it in the chat you're not believing
me you don't believe that someone typed
that [ __ ] out i mean it may be someone
you know [ __ ] with me i don't yeah i
don't think i i don't think i look like
leonardo who never i'm much better
looking
let's face it way better looking than
leonardo gabriel [ __ ] that guy [ __ ] that
guy no no i i mean i could see how you
know some pasty white guy with a weird
beard and a little bit of a
you know a haircut like this could you
know it could
resemble
resemble the good looks of leonardo
dicaprio yeah i know i'm just saying no
i could i could see that you know on a
good on a good thursday you know you'll
look like that oh so today today yeah
yeah yeah thursday so today yeah the
hair's a good day there's no i'm not
having not a bad air day yesterday was
kind of it was iffy it was heavy but
today it's working out all right so
we're gonna have a rain i mean as long
as you have a good hair day for
tomorrow's bonehead of the week then
that's right well you know that's a good
point i got we got a lot of
announcements it's a damn good thing i'm
having a good hair day for this uh biden
speech tonight because we are gonna
guest host the midas touch podcast
tonight
on the the midas touch networks youtube
channel i put the link in the
description below so when the show's
over you can go click the link set your
reminder for tonight to watch the midas
touch podcast we will be bringing you
biden's remarks on the soul of the
nation as they're calling it we're
bringing them live to you seven eastern
uh we'll we'll talk to the mizella's
brothers we'll let biden do his little
speech i don't know how long it's
supposed to be it's like 30 minutes or
something like that i'm not really
because it goes from
7 45 eastern right yeah we got this late
yesterday we were waiting we were
waiting all day yesterday to hear what
the the timing was it it was and it
finally got scheduled and released and
we're hoping that we're hoping that it
stays the same time they don't [ __ ]
change it but um i i think that's what
took them so long
i mean what what was it was seven it was
7 45 eastern and then the was the end
time 9 p.m eastern i yeah so i'm not
sure what coverage is going to be after
i don't know if they're going to if
they're going to do statements after or
take statements after um that's how long
that's how long our camera feed was
going to be on so right but we're going
to start our coverage at 7 eastern
because likely biden will be up at about
eight eastern yeah because that is truly
prime time eight eastern is what they
consider the prime spot so that would be
where the president's probably gonna
speak is right at the top of the hour at
eight o'clock so we're going to come in
an hour before talk listen to him talk
then we'll have some stuff afterwards
with the mizellas brothers so it's a
special edition special edition of the
midas touch podcast don't miss it
tonight over the midas touch network's
youtube channel again when the show's
done here the link is in the description
below you can go right over there and
click the link set your reminder so you
don't forget tonight to watch that show
um that will have president biden's
remarks of the soul of the nation the
soul of the nation i kind of like that
soul of the nation you know um well he i
mean like during his campaign he talked
about repairing the sultanation right
this is a moment to kind of you know
he's i think
this is a nice comprehensive look at the
things that he's accomplished over the
last two months especially with uh a
split majority a split uh
senate and and and a bunch of
republicans in both the house and the
senate were unwilling
to
come to the table and actually negotiate
on many things right and their most
recent thing that they want to you know
kind of crush the soul of the nation is
suing the government for trying to help
students this is going to be their loan
forgiveness backfire on them
just like row
when they tried to when they sued the
government
and made sure and and with dobbs to make
sure to tear down roe and overturn roe
at the supreme court they worked decades
and decades to get these bought and paid
for fascists on the supreme court to
tear down women's bodily autonomy they
did it and it backfired on them it's not
even it's and it's not even that too
like you have to remember also the
the uh the american health care act
right like you you look at
obamacare and at first you know you had
a republican and you still have
republicans that are like trying to bash
in trying to strip it of everything
but it wasn't until it went into effect
people like oh this is actually pretty
good like
this is actually helping this is better
than it used to be right exactly like
it's not because it's not perfect right
it's right well and there's parts of it
that are really kind of [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah the reason why is because it holds
up it holds up corporate insurance
account right as there's pre-existing
conditions like that's a huge one but
they hold up them as the beneficiaries
of really the health care system right
yeah the the insurance companies are the
beneficiaries which that that's the
difference between social medicine and
medicine for profit like we have with
the proper modem in this country is the
beneficiaries are the insurance
companies in this country mainly there's
some hospitals doctors that sort of
thing but they're that's their job
that's their business but the insurance
companies are the big beneficiary in
other countries they look at the
citizens as the beneficiaries of their
health care system not not the insurance
companies so it's just a different
paradigm to change right but you can't
you can't change it by saying universal
healthcare and [ __ ] you can't change it
with
the affordable healthcare what you gotta
do is say hey people shouldn't go broke
because of a medical bill right that's
that's that's the thought because that
gets you in this mindset that the person
who is receiving the health care is the
beneficiary of the health care system
not the corporations not the insurance
companies not the big hospitals and the
big corporations that are milking money
and and taking all the profit with their
profit motive in the system i mean
free you know having affordable health
care or just you know universal health
here should be an inalienable right like
it should be something i am born as a
citizen or become a citizen into this
country and i should have the luxury
hell i don't think you should be a
citizen as long as your feet are in this
country right right yeah i think you
should i think you should be able to
receive medical care i mean that's it's
the same way in canada like if you go to
canada something happens you break your
arm you go to the hospital
that's it you're in canada baby
you're in canada that's true it it's
it's it's you you do not go broke
because of a medical bill in canada and
it should be the same way here we should
have that mindset on a lot of different
things but you know what's funny is
we're sitting here talking about
obamacare
and that rewinds the clock back way back
to 2010. yep and if you rewind it just a
little further to 2008
do you remember who ran for for on the
republican ticket in 2008 do you
remember who it was
oh you against barack obama and the
current president
you betcha you betcha you sound like you
know no i do
you would which person you want first do
you want well i mean who who who was the
guy who was running around trying to
trying to smash up this idea that barack
obama wasn't the citizen he was some
kind of secret terrorist muslim who was
that gay i forget who was that gay
he's some kind of war hero or something
gentleman john mccain that's it that's
it now who did he pick who did he pick
to be his fight because she was a
superstar i remember this clearly yeah
she i mean she came out with lipsticks
on pigs and all kinds of [ __ ] yeah well
was it lipstick on a pig or was the
lipstick on a bulldog no pig
pig i think so one i thought it was the
difference between what's the difference
between a mom and a in a pit bull or
something like that or bulldog was that
what it was i thought yeah and she goes
it's lipstick oh wait she's pretty sure
it's i thought it was lipstick on a pig
because she's a [ __ ] fascist pig and
she puts lipstick on i don't know that's
just
i know maybe that's what my memory but
who what was her name what the [ __ ] oh
yeah uh sarah bobert oh that's right i
see i get those two confused yeah yeah
lauren yeah it was
it says
they say the difference between a hockey
mom and a pitbull that's what a lipstick
she's a hockey i was like i'm pretty
sure it was a dog she's a hockey mom
yeah yeah yeah hockey
yeah yeah cause they play hockey up
there in atlanta well you know the
miracle team you know right is that
where they they practice up in alaska
[ __ ] i don't know i don't know about
hockey you ever seen a movie with kurt
russell no
no
no you're telling me to watch something
on on something yeah i was telling you
to watch the rehearsal the rehearsal on
hbo it's a show with nathan fielder if
anyone has watched
nathan for you on comedy central it's
like this
it's is it funny yeah it's funny it's
like it's it's humor it's it's cringe
comedy you know and turn they like oh if
you ever remember like the dumb
starbucks they made years ago no oh well
i know it's like in my neighborhood that
they made one years ago and it was a
whole thing but he had a show and now
he's got a new show okay on hbo
rehearsal okay yeah well i'll see if i
can check it out because i like
lighthearted shows i can't i i can't
watch and i started watching like all
these murder dramas and murder like mini
series and [ __ ] like on netflix
there's a time they figured out what
they were like people like this stuff i
was trying to figure out how my wife was
going to kill me no i mean because it
gets it starts to get in your head
you're like whoa is she poisoning me
whoa is she going to push me down the
stairs
why does she have such long kitchen
knives no i'm just yeah i just i just
watched that manti tail one the uh oh
yeah i'm
the girlfriend i haven't watched that
yeah that one's good i remember i
watched another untold i forget which
one it was the other night but there was
and one they've got a few i didn't know
that that's what it was and one that was
a really good one
that's on my that's on my list to watch
it's a good one it's a good one you
should definitely check those out you
did you know what you know what we need
to do because we got a lot of news to
get to gabe but january as much as i
want to talk about top secret documents
and i know we're going to today we can
yeah yeah help but talk about i
guarantee it'll come up tomorrow during
the show or definitely during it of the
week we're we're definitely not going to
be able to stop talking about top secret
documents for weeks and months yeah
but i want to get back to january 6
because there's a lot of january 6 news
this morning
i mean it just boys popping off this
that this news is starting there's new
indictments even so let's get into it
let's get to the [ __ ] list roundup where
we round up all the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends let's start the
countdown
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome back to the show
you've reached the part where we round
up all the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends on the [ __ ] list roundup
robin says we call those shows murder
porn
that is that is definitely uh murder
porn it is there's a lot of them on
there like yeah like you could spend
weeks just watching people murder people
on netflix
this is the thing why i mean
you like watching a lot of people no no
no no i'm saying like that like the
whole like the whole story you know
stories yeah well you can think of
cereal for that one serial's the one
that broke kind of through as the
podcast format and then now everyone
does murder you know like unsolved
mystery stuff well i guess the unsolved
mystery was like the original that's the
og one right right and then now
netflix which also uh got the rights to
um unsolved mysteries now they do all
these like crazy serial mystery
unsolved cases kind of thing and yeah
they are very very addictive they're
popular you know i'll give you some um
unsolved mystery oh yeah some some some
some um some unknown information matthew
mcconaughey did you notice he appeared
on one of the unsolved mystery
episodes yeah he was an actor on he was
one of the you know that because they
reenact the scenes
on unsolved mysteries i i watched an
episode years ago
and it was an old episode and it had
matthew mcconaughey on it look it up
look i'm telling you look at that i'm
looking it
there it is all right
episode
season 5 episode 12 1992.
if you if you want to doubt me you can
but if you don't want to doubt me or if
you want to advertise that you shouldn't
doubt me get your get your get your
doubt me merch store.thetonymichaels.com
shirts hoodies stickers
coffee mugs
everything
don't doubt me i'm telling you i know
it's only just a little part he played a
little part in one of the little stories
that they had i believe he play i don't
know if he plays a person that gets
murdered or he plays the murderer or a
witness i can't remember but it's just a
small little part he appears and then he
it's like
the the guys who made uh
true detective were like
we got him we know it we know who needs
to be in it
matthew mcgowan well i i don't know if
this was before he was really i don't
know what year it was or like when it
happened he was he was just uh he was
she was a murder victim that's what he
was so he was the victim yeah that's
what i thought and i from what i
remember this was years ago but i
remember him being in a white t-shirt is
he in a white t-shirt uh nope well
hold on let me go back don't don't don't
make me a liar nope nope not a white
t-shirt no no no
no he had a shirt that was unbuttoned
and he had the sleeves cut off oh okay
well yeah i remember him maybe it's just
like matthew mcconaughey in a white
t-shirt it's like the white t-shirt
would be him in um
confused yeah when he's in the car you
know and he's like that's what it is
getting younger it's what it is see i'm
i'm i'm confused yeah you're mashing
right mcconaughey universe mcconaughey
cinematic universe the mcu i guess the
doubt me isn't uh as
rock solid as it should be yeah i don't
know let's get to the tweety tweets and
training turns did you hear jeannie
thomas email more lawmakers i heard you
try to open up the government oh man it
wasn't just arizona she was like nope
one state isn't enough we gotta go for
two i thought i had it here and who
knows there might be a third or a fourth
in there but
well
she definitely um here kyle has it here
as breaking washington i read part of
this washington post article um
jeannie thomas pressed lawmakers to
overturn joe biden's 2020 victory not
only in arizona because i think there
was 29 lawmakers there was 29 in arizona
that she contacted now as previously
reported but also in a second
battleground state wisconsin according
to the emails i thought it was michigan
it's wisconsin too wait a second am i
missing am i doing am i doing the whole
matthew mcconaughey white t-shirt thing
with the sheets here oh yeah look i'm
just inside
instead of like an mi initial right you
know like abbreviation yeah
i'm doing that
look it's it's you know i you sure
you're not hungover from karaoke it
could be it could be the jagermeister it
could be the jagermeister
okay what what you don't like
jagermeister get the [ __ ] out of here
i'm just it's just not my put some hair
on your chest my friend look i'm good
with my bare chest you know
jagermeister who baby it's some solid
stuff it's some style and stuff uh but
the washington post article lays out
that i think she contacted two lawmakers
i believe they are um if i'm not
mistaken
uh one is yes she is
the
uh uh she's a senator
in wisconsin
and the other one is a just a state rep
but uh the significance here is she is
the
the uh kathy
burner
bernier i don't know then chair of the
she at the time she was the chair of the
senate elections committee
um this represents the senator that
jeannie thomas
sent an email to now apparently
she sent it almost at the exact same
time that she sent emails to the arizona
lawmakers
um which only shows conspiracy and also
coordination with between states to try
to overturn a free and fair election
right um and i believe which is you know
i just want to point out what the
obvious here which is it is insane
that we have a sitting supreme court
justice
and his wife
jenny thomas
is just openly just emailing people who
have influence over these state
elections on a national
election
which which he would he clarence thomas
the supreme court justice would have
jurisdiction over and he does not recuse
himself from any january six cases the
fact that impeachment was in order the
fact that that is a thing that like
everyone's like yeah well that's it i
mean like
even even the fact that there was one
person right or even the fact that she
was texting mark meadows repeatedly to
talk about how she was pushing all these
q anon theories and how uh biden you
know we're okay with biden being
anointed like he's some king and we need
to make sure that trump is the true even
texas
gitmo and [ __ ] just yeah why crazy ass
just the wildest craziest q and [ __ ] you
can think of she was texting the chief
of staff who was standing next to donald
trump who was the president at the time
directly into the why is his brain yeah
why is that okay none of that none of
that should be okay just like the stolen
documents none of that is okay wait
those weren't exciting
there's were his documents god damn it
and he had him in a carton he had him in
when he stole them gabe he put him in a
carton he had them nice and secure in
between the time frames in a carton the
fbi are the ones who made a mess and
took a picture of it that's that's the
illegality though all i'm saying is if
you look if you look at the carpet just
quick note if you look at the carpet in
the photos that he takes with people
like kyle rittenhouse kyle rittenhouse's
family lauren beaubert or anyone else
who came into his office the carpet is
the same design as the carpet that the
photos were taken which is like
again i asked this question you know a
few weeks ago which was who
was shown these documents i'm still
curious i want to know who had access
that room
we're going to talk about show that off
because i'm going to show the picture of
the carpet so we're going to talk about
it here but there's new more january 6
news this morning
kelly surreal
an attorney this is how kyle this is
what is being reported an attorney for
the oath keepers which
if you remember when stuart rhodes got
arrested and the other oath keepers were
indicted and they arrested them and
detained them kelly cerrill was his it
seemed like his girlfriend at the time
she was an attorney
not much of one apparently she's
trump should hire her really honestly
yeah yeah
why not why not i mean at this point you
might as well he might as well get a
whole team of [ __ ] idiots but kelly's
surreal you remember
when stuart got detained
she became the national
leader yeah the head of it she kind of
she kind of declared herself that right
right and then several weeks after that
as the pressure ramped up on them she
said oh no i'm not the national leader
i'm i'm not doing that yeah yeah that's
not a thing i'm doing
and now this morning she has been
charged as part of that conspiracy to
obstruct the january 6 proceeding of
congress if you read the charges here
count one
is obstruction of yeah four counts uh
count one is a conspiracy to obstruct
official proceeding which is part of
that um conspiracy that the other others
that oh like stewart rhodes is involved
in obstruction and official proceeding
and aiding and abetting uh oh um because
that's not conspiracy that's just actual
obstruction
entering and remaining in a restricted
building and grounds that means she
actually entered the actual building
there but count four i think is very
important here
this is not a conspiracy charge this is
an outright charge which means that the
department of justice and the grand jury
has evidence
that she may allegedly participated in
tampering with documents
this is very important
that charge is very very very [ __ ]
important in this case i know it's the
count four
but the reason why this was important is
because gabe that is one that they can
[ __ ] prove big time if they if they
have evidence that the grand jury is
willing to and we don't know we don't
know what documents that tampered with
right right we don't know what documents
at this point um and i haven't read the
full indictment yet it may give some
some indication in there i just went to
this front page i know who kelly surreal
is um i actually i i tweeted back and
forth with her i believe she's on
twitter i believe are she was at one
time i don't know what she's doing she
says some racist [ __ ] [ __ ] on twitter
yeah race is [ __ ] [ __ ] and she is the
trumpiest of the trump and that is one
reason why i think stuart rhodes kind of
went down this road is because
now kelly surreal is it kind of seems to
believe a lot of this q anon garbage a
lot of these conspiracy theories i think
she's still really close with alex jones
um
she's she's very um in the the white
supremacist part of the uh the para
militia you know kind of universe um so
kelly surreal being indicted is a big
thing i think we should um
probably consider um recording with
dakota maybe over the weekend so that we
can get his take on kelly surreal and
what it means to have
um stuart rhodes kind of number two his
his right hand gal
now being indicted as part of the
conspiracy
and why it took so long i think that is
another question
that is going to come so i think that's
very important well i mean again you
know a lot of people you know i think
even before
this bombshell of mar-a-lago came out
you know everyone's like oh
merrick garland what are you dragging
your feet what's going on why aren't you
working fast enough right keep in mind
you know and now all of this stuff is
companies bubbling up the surface like
look they're not just working on one
thing they're working on several things
at the same time and no one
no one had any sort of insight that's
how [ __ ] tight-lipped that ship is
over there at the doj they're able to
work on very high profile cases and no
one is talking well
besides the buffoon in chief oh he's
talking
oh he's [ __ ] talking he's on some
kind of [ __ ] traitor radio show i
don't know what the [ __ ] this is body by
what does that say i have no idea dina
360. i don't know
who is this lady i have no idea
why do they always have american flags
behind them because like a personality
it is it is their core personality it is
america despite defectors like don't you
know obviously ruin the american flag by
putting it on different you know
products but
or here nor there but the face of their
orange deity all right and [ __ ] yeah
yeah exactly i don't know i i mean i
like the american like i think it's a
great symbol of democracy i think it's i
think it's time that we reclaim
right but with this with these people
thinking that it's some kind of symbol
for fascism is gross it's like you know
you guys you guys have the nazi swastika
flag you guys have the confederate flag
like those are right keep those like you
clearly want banners you you fly them at
the same time
let's not disparage the actual image and
representation of the american flag with
your racist fascist [ __ ] well you
know um
everyone in the everyone in the chat
tell us tell us what you think are we
going to reclaim this flag this november
are we going to make sure that american
patriotism is claimed back for equality
and equity and tell us in the chat here
because we got a ton of people here in
the chat uh today so make sure if you're
in the chat make sure you're also
subscribing to the podcast here but tell
us in the chat what you think about the
american flag and these morons these
fascists using this their fascist banner
when that's not what that [ __ ]
means at all
but this i don't know who this is and
apparently he can't get any kind of
national interviews
he can he's got to go on this whatever
the hell this trader i think a lot of a
lot of a lot of networks especially fox
uh i mean i haven't even seen him on
sean hannity lately no i don't know if
i'm wrong on that but i haven't seen him
there and so like a lot of me is
thinking
that even the like higher ups at fox
like do not
touch this [ __ ] right with a 10 foot
pole because he's going to say something
and and we're it's going to come back
and we're going to get sued again we're
already getting sued the problem is is
that the fox news that bit is going to
end up in court like several fox news
bits has ended up in the january 6th
select committee hearing but let's
listen to their orange deity the former
guy the cheeto dust mobster the stealer
of documents let's listen to
how he
openly
admits to crime we write this wrong what
can you do
so i met with a number of times but i
met with and i'm financially supporting
people that are incredible and they were
in my office actually two days ago it's
very much on my mind
okay so who was in his office he's
talking about january sixers
he's talking about people who are under
indictment for january 6. he met with
these people in his office now remember
i don't know if this is the same office
or not but this guy in his office he
keeps top secret documents in his desk
drawers yeah that's a thing we know now
we know that this [ __ ] keeps
toxic documents our highest secrets of
our country in his desk drawer and he's
got a bunch of [ __ ] traders in his
goddamn office not only that he's giving
him money and i wonder i wonder it seems
a bit like a conflict of interest but
sure well it seems like it it also seems
really sus when he's got top secret
documents uh in his desktop the [ __ ]
traitor in chief here let's listen
it's a disgrace what they've done to
them what they've done to these people
it's just
you know he could have pardoned all
these [ __ ] right yeah he could
have done that he could have done that
also
how much do you want to be right he had
14 days yeah he had plenty of time to
you know from the six to say okay got
two weeks i got a i got a fortnight
amount of time to
to pardon these [ __ ] right but
the other thing too is
how much do you think of what he's
saying is true
because how would these january 6 people
know like you know maybe someone's
talking they're like were you invited
like i wasn't invited were you invited i
wasn't invited you would never really
know who was invited who wasn't invited
and so part of me is thinking like do
you think he's really having these
people there maybe maybe he's dumb
enough to do that but i'm also like just
[ __ ] ryan or he's making [ __ ] up
because he's agreeing right well what he
says afterwards he's trying to garnish
support is what he's trying to do what
what's the hell is that that that
[ __ ] real estate agent down in texas
she thought she was so tough and all
that [ __ ] she she was taking pictures of
broken windows what was it jenna ryan
was that her goddamn name oh jenna ryan
yeah yeah she's the one who went to
january 6 and was like yeah
and then when she got in trouble she got
in front of the news camera she's like
oh he's going to pardon me he's going to
give me a pardon and then when he didn't
partner he she's like that bastard
didn't pardon me like no he's he doesn't
care about it you care about anyone and
give a [ __ ] about i don't even care
about his own family no [ __ ] no let's
listen to how he's gonna he's gonna when
he wins in 2024 if he runs
give him money and send him money uh
that way he can pardon all the [ __ ]
traitors listen it's graceful and
and mostly i mean you know it's it's the
firemen they're policemen they're
they're people in the military
yeah they sure were people that were
you know you look at what took place
with the police where they're ushering
them in and so many different things and
so cops good and then in the same breath
cops bad like he literally just said
he's like oh they're pl they were great
people they were police officers and
then them dirty cops let them
good cops in to go
[ __ ] on the walls and to try to overturn
the government make me king what the
[ __ ] is this guy talking about man
how how in the [ __ ] how in the [ __ ] do
we still have to listen to this [ __ ]
buffoon and i and a lot of people are
going to say well tony you're playing
this clip this is important folks
he is cat calling for stochastic
terrorism here listen
we're working on it very hard we're
working with legals you know there's
radical leftists of these people are
sick there's something wrong with them
nobody's ever seen anything like this
and they don't mind everything you know
they were telling me about some of these
some of the legal people on the other
side they're the most cold-hearted
people they don't care
about families they don't care about
anything they're just and you see what
they're doing with the sentencing and i
will tell you and i'm looking at it very
carefully i've i've studied it i study
cases and he doesn't contribute he can
barely he's never studied anything in
his entire life uh other other than well
how how can we make sure that we defraud
we defraud people yeah
he has trouble he makes up [ __ ] on it
you know makes [ __ ] up blames a
teleprompter you know
the guy is who is this lady did you see
her reactions
she's really animated
she's like
amen brother amen brother got a got a
face for you know radio tv radio right
now got it gotta animate it hey hey
probably
for someone who looks like leonardo
dicaprio i resemble that remark no no
what i mean what i mean by that is you
got to be animated in here because
you're just sitting there and listening
so like yeah
stop talking if that's right right well
yeah and so like if you're coming in to
actually watch the video version you're
like i'm just staring at someone
listening to someone like the reaction
you gotta like stay somewhat animated
right well here's obviously fake but
sure it's so important here because
he this is where he's doing his
interviews yeah
he is the former
president
of the united states of america
and no one will listen to him whine
other than some [ __ ] weird ass
obscure
radio show yeah he's the former
president of the united states this
would be like us having barack obama on
here i know that sounds like oh well but
really do you think we would you think
barack obama would come out here and
talk to the tony michaels [ __ ] no he
wouldn't no he wouldn't he wouldn't
because he's i don't know i kind of have
i kind of i don't know i kind of have
like i'm holding out oh oh he never he
would definitely come talk to you yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah yeah he
definitely died this is uh by the way
this woman is wendy bell wendy bell and
the show is called aim body by aim 360.
what the [ __ ] does that mean
is that like some kind of body body
well it's a nutritionist
oh she's a snake oil salesman this makes
this is making more and more sense here
this is i'm really starting to put this
picture together now that we know that
she's a snake oil sales person
she's also
new she's on newsmax too it sounds oh
really well even better wendy bell
common sense that's what it's called
wendy bell common sense okay well let's
let's listen to this dribble not the
common sense let's listen to the dribble
missions should be made we have to do
that because you know they have some
good lawyers but even the good lawyers
they can't be fraudulent judges you get
before amen you get so much of these
judges that that are so so nasty and so
angry mean
the sentences
and i will tell you i will be very very
favorable about about full pardons there
you go i decide to run and if i win i
will be looking very very strongly about
pardons
okay hold on hold on so he's dangling
the carrot right out in front of these
voters to say or you know this small
group of j6 and j6 uh
sympathizers to say look guys
if you vote for me and
i win right all right also it's like
he's not gonna run
if i run
and you vote for me and i win which is
like a few hurdles to get through then i
will consider
pardoning these january six people
well he's just taking he's been what i
see here is he's begging for support
by giving by
by
that is the only card he has left he has
nothing left to actually leverage to be
like what am i offering you the american
people did i make your lives better
actually you didn't did i improve the
economy no no you didn't no did i make
sure to to care for other human life
nope you said i take no responsibility
what about lowering taxes who do you
lower taxes for oh who do you think are
the rich people there's like a certain
class there you have the rich yep and
this student debt program is the exact
opposite of that yep i mean it just goes
on and on here here he is on the trader
news network
real american sunrise trader tv so i
don't know i guess boys
um this is the same network that uh
charlie kirk and [ __ ] faceplate and
then and steve bannon yeah steve
bannon's on there yeah decomposing
the pine piper the of the trees in this
piece of [ __ ] the domestic terrace piper
steve bannon well let's listen to how
the cheeto dust mobster describes those
documents what the fbi does and doesn't
do let's listen a lot of people think
that when you walk into my office i have
confidential documents or whatever it
may be you'll be classified but
okay okay you do have them in your
office man they found them there you
admitted to it right you even said
they're in cartons which why did he say
cartons what the [ __ ] curtains make it
makes it sound even worse because when i
imagine like oh we had a carton of this
i imagine a carton is bigger than like a
box right right i was a container a
folder like we had a few folders and you
imagine like a stack of [ __ ] but you say
carton like that's a case of top secret
documents yeah
when you say card when you say card i
think wow you had a lot of [ __ ] in your
office that shouldn't have been there
well let's let's continue but i had
confidential documents spread out all
over my far floor
and uh like a slob
like
you are a slob dude have you ever seen
pictures of his [ __ ] office and yeah
i'll pull one i'll get you one right now
but yeah they it is always a mess so
it's like one the idea that if they were
sloppily laying on the ground which
no one
got the impression and we talked about
this yesterday no one looking at the
photo thought wow
they they they put it on they just threw
those things directly on the ground a
bunch of jerks this is the same guy who
said oh they went through melania's
closet and didn't you know essentially
saying like they didn't fold the laundry
back that's not their [ __ ] job man
you're hiding something and they need to
go through and make sure that it's not
hidden you know
in some random [ __ ] panty drawer and
then melania's team's like husband not
allowed in a room husband not loud in
room
so so when you have trump being like oh
they made it look dude one your your
office is 100 already messy as it is and
two
that's called laying it out on the
ground and the amount of space that is
available
do you think he also has a hellhole like
an l-shaped ruler no like any idea that
someone would like oh they they they put
it there to make it seem like i was like
no they didn't well here's the thing is
that picture has the little the the 2a
little marker right to mark what piece
of evidence and what picture that is
because they'll use that in court
they'll say this is item it's getting
exhibited 2a and you'll see
right that's how they collect evidence
what what no one is really saying is
1a
3a 4a
2b 3b like there's a lot
to think that i only took one
[ __ ] picture you are out of
your mind they were taken there was
someone taking [ __ ] loads of pictures
shitloads of pictures when they were
marking this evidence for them to get it
so
and and when you show this picture of
the desk i'm going to describe you and
tell you i'm going to tell you why it is
so important
what what this desk is and why he what
he has in his desk but listen to the
rest of what this
bonehead
[ __ ] confesses to
i'm sitting there reading these
documents all day long or somebody else
would be he literally that's that's
literally he's telling on himself here
he's like yeah i'm a slob i got [ __ ]
everywhere of course i had documents
thrown all over my office and in my
drawer cause i was reading them and i
was having other people read them of
course i did like he's admitting it like
i mean he's he's projecting but this is
what he does it's so it's so dishonest
yeah you are
and some people were concerned because
they said gee
you know that's a strange scene you look
at the floor and you see documents right
they have cover sheets of documents no
they put them there john and they put
him there in a messy fashion and then
they took a picture
and they released it to the public and
this is what we're dealing with
abolish the fbi they take pictures
documents
the exact quote was photographically
released into the public and he also put
picture in quotes yeah picture
again picture in quotes
picture uh
definitely expect a video you've used i
sent you the script last night but the
videos
wait wait there's a script there's a
script
okay so i'm going to show you this
picture here now i want to make sure
that the audience knows exactly what's
going on down here at mar-a-lago because
this is super important now this is
a picture of his office in trump tower
correct
and this isn't even the messiest photo
also no this is like it cleaned up a bit
yeah right now i want you to pay
attention
to the [ __ ] on his desk now it looks
like a [ __ ] mess i mean it's a total
disaster it's a [ __ ] mess which i you
know i i when i have desks they can be a
mess yeah yeah but i want to make sure
that everyone looks at this disc and
evaluates it properly of what is on this
desk now this thing has markers here
but here here's what i want to tell you
there is a damn good reason why he had
three classified documents in his desk
drawer
and it's because of who donald trump is
and you just have to look at this
picture to know exactly why you had him
there when you look at pictures of his
desk cause there's a lot of them out
there from trump tower yep
every time there's a stack there's
stacks of magazines that he's on the
cover there's like here it has the
[ __ ] let me pull down our banner here
um if i can make it work here uh
down here at the bottom corner down here
number eight you see that there that is
a trump bumper sticker he's got
newspaper number nine here stacking
newspaper that's all the same goddamn
newspaper those are
he does not read that [ __ ] right now
here's what i want to say the reason why
dude has three classified documents
in his [ __ ] desk drawer
is because he's bragging about him the
same way as he has all this [ __ ] on his
desk here he's bragging about it to
whoever comes in look at this magazine
look at this article i'm in oh my god
look at the
great bumpers well you do remember you
remember the controversy about the time
magazine
oh yeah where he faked it yeah he faked
it and then time well from from what i
remember time was like uh that that
never happened uh do not do not tell
people that's a thing right well and
that's in that but that's but
can you pull up the written house photo
can you do can you find that one for me
we'll go to that yeah i'll i'll show you
my tweet that i uh oh okay yeah yeah
send me your tweet
and uh actually uh i may have retweeted
it already oh there you go yeah let's
see if you can find it there because i'm
i'm searching but but here's the thing
is it super important to understand
why he had these in his desk drawer he
had him in his desk drawer so he had him
handy when he was doing his bragging
just like he's bragging about the
magazine sitting there and the the news
articles and the books that he signed
the books because he'll do this too
someone will want him to put a forward
in a book he'll have that book because
oh look they wanted me they they they
wanted me like jesse waters
which was which is well actually copied
from an amazon review
or synopsis that he got called off where
he's like i would never do that and it's
like dude it's forbidden you did it you
did it so um so this is this is really
important um when you're when you're
comparing these two pictures here if i
can
find the damn thing
[Music]
but when you're comparing the pictures
of the carpet where kyle rittenhouse and
others have been in the office
um
in his office
and this is what he does is he brags
about [ __ ] that's why he had those
[ __ ] in the desk drawer yeah
and so he could pull back like look what
i got look what i got [ __ ]
look what i got because it's just
amazing
yeah that's the uh okay
that's serious
here is um the picture
of
the
and this is gabe's tweet here
gabe says i still want to know so look
at the carpet here this tacky ass
[ __ ] motel six tile carpet yeah we
talked about this yesterday this is
actually one of the worst crimes of all
this pictures the [ __ ] carpet the
carpet's horrible
picks this [ __ ] carpet out what the
[ __ ] is this but but here's the thing
with the carpet
is look at look at the same tacky ass
carpet now this is a picture you can't
see it in this one because dumbass she's
got her let's go brandon nazi dress on
whatever she was trying to copy aoc
horrible
horrible redo horrible horrible [ __ ]
redo here by the way but he's standing
in front of the picture of kim jong-un
because this is where he stands to take
these stupid thumbs-up pictures and then
this one here again you can see up that
at the top there's the picture where he
loves
to brag about where he
shook a murderous dictators
and autocrats handy he would love to be
kim jong-un of america yeah and you see
who is standing in the picture with him
uh the [ __ ] murderer kyle rittenhouse
that's right sue me kyle i said it
you're a [ __ ] murderer
that's true
he did he did murder
and
he said kyle couldn't even do the
decency for trump and put his thumbs up
you see that
well he's probably too nervous because
he just touched top secret documents and
kyler in house's dumb ass dad and
stupid-ass mom yeah my mom been charged
with crimes yep the mom who drove him
across state lines look at the carpet
here this is the same spot where lauren
bobert was standing mm-hmm
the same goddamn spot is this in his
office this is in his god damn you mean
kyle rittenhouse was in the same goddamn
room as top secret documents just just
arm links away in a goddamn drawer
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me now it is 100 on
brand for trump right
and you know you know gabe you know for
a [ __ ] fact that these these [ __ ]
[ __ ] here in this picture got a
chance to go over and gander
gander at the classified documents that
trump likes to brag about yeah and it
may not even be the worst
classified documents or like top secret
documents but i guarantee he showed them
something
something was like oh you look at this
stuff that i still got look at these
mementos you know and then eric trump's
coming he's like hey you can say mentos
he's like no no eric i didn't say mentos
i said mementos
not fresh in your breath you need to
freshen your breath but god damn but
here it is here it is folks i know it
seems like a conspiracy theory
but i'm telling you i'm telling you with
trump
he is predictably unpredictable yep and
the predictably unpredictable thing here
is that he showed this little [ __ ]
[ __ ]
he showed this little [ __ ] [ __ ]
our national secrets and to be honest
with you gabe
i don't know
if that's not where they started to find
out about this [ __ ] because in most in
most instances
when prosecutors find out about crime
it's because some dumb [ __ ] out there is
bragging about it yeah and what [ __ ]
brand for kyle rittenhouse he uh he's
gonna sue joe biden i'm gonna steal joe
biden
that's because joe biden won't return
his phone calls right or won't return
his message to say i requested an
apology from joe biden joe biden's like
what
the [ __ ] dude i gotta run a country
right now i have to help the economy i
have to rebuild the infrastructure i
need to make sure that students like
your dumb ass whoever decide to go to
college and have student loans and they
have debt that they're forgiven
right well here he is here he is big
mouth little murderer kyle rittenhouse
tough guy
in the same room as classified documents
same carpet same room lauren bobert was
in there
i mean her husband likes to show people
[ __ ] he likes to get stuff out she was
there she was there at the bowling
island she was totally okay with it and
then they got married so you know love
love
lovely couple
uh but do you think jason was in the
room too do you think he was in that
office too i bet you he was the one
taking the photo
it might have been do you think do you
think he had his wiener out when he did
all that i don't know he i i hear he
likes to take it out in front of people
so i would imagine you know there's a
title for people who like take photos
it's called uh the instagram boyfriend
right this is the guy who's always there
in the boom boom yeah
so he's like the instagram husband just
the photo yeah you know she she's there
you know all around trump and oozing
over his sorry wrong phrase uh
just kind of adoring trump
and what he uh
and what he stands for right paula says
oh tony oh tony what i do i i didn't
take i didn't do it i didn't i didn't we
didn't take the photo we didn't show any
documents we report you decide okay yeah
i don't know
i think that's fox news and and then we
it might be yeah i don't know i just re
i just tell you what that is out there
in the universe
you do with it what you want you can say
you know anything you want about me oh
tony i like that
oh tony and she's laughing of course
she's laughing so
i'm saying
i'm saying definitely saying that yes
yes it is it is the truth kyle
rittenhouse was in the same goddamn room
as classified documents
there's there's not much denying it now
uh i mean that the fact that whether he
showed him or not you know i guess the
fingerprint um
examination might tell us something
about that
um and i'm sure there's a lot of people
that been in that office that have
touched that [ __ ] that are freaking the
[ __ ] out and i would imagine that those
people had become informants and it
wouldn't put it past kyle rittenhouse to
be a little [ __ ] snitch and be an
informant on donald trump about class
classified documents of what he saw and
what he didn't see because apparently
apparently according to trump's lawyer a
lot of people a lot of people went in
that [ __ ] room a lot of them
well she said what's his what's his
stupid ass's name what's her name alina
habba i actually i posted i posted the
recent episode of uh
shitty legal takes
should we play that one or should we
play the actual clip
no no no
what because the whole clip is in there
that's a whole okay so we should play we
should we should play the yeah okay our
latest episode of our our legal sitcom
shitty legal takes let me find it here
you post it on her channel did you make
it public or is it private no no no no i
put it on twitter
oh you did oh i didn't know that this
morning it was happening during the show
oh i see i see see i'm behind here i i
would have if you would have said
something i would have retweeted all
right we're about to
we're about to here is the um here's the
here's the
what's her name again i've i already
forgot alina
have a nice day
oh what an idiot
oh this is great these shitty legal
takes we played a couple a couple weeks
ago when they had some [ __ ] right after
the it wasn't right
or was it two weeks ago i don't know
this is getting away from me we've been
talking about top secret documents for a
while but let's listen
this photo
i just want to say that the photo from
that we've shown so far and we've talked
about this week
it is
it is going to leave a lasting imprint
on our history as a country the moment
right everyone's got a photo of like
that was the moment when blank this is
the moment when we figured out
what exactly trump had beyond just what
was in a redacted affidavit right right
this is something to say like yeah we're
not [ __ ] around this is actually real
and this is just some of the stuff
some of the stuff that he had
right well
yeah the smokey mirror says hubba hubba
well you know that is not a bad point
because it feels like to me
that donald trump has picked out some of
his lawyers for a particular reason not
because they have good legal takes and
you're gonna see here with these shitty
legal takes let's play
what's happened is now they've put this
picture out so that you would assume and
i'm somebody who has been and the press
loves to talk about this especially
today i'm somebody that has been in his
office i've seen it this is not the way
his office looks they give you this
appearance that you walk in and there's
these top secret documents just thrown
about hey
they don't understand
something could be marked top secret
could be marked classified the
presidential records act
he would have said this is declassified
it doesn't get a new marking all the
time he's left the office it is a
complete public spectacle and i'm not
really going to stand by it anymore you
know i personally have gotten
intimidated people have tried to
intimidate me it's not going to work you
can't just put a picture like this and
say look
did the fbi do that or was that the way
that room looked before they went in
there do you have any any first-hand
knowledge yeah yeah i'm sure you've seen
the press today i do have first-hand
knowledge as you know i have been down
there i'm down there frequently i have
never seen that i have never ever seen
that that is not the way his office is
anybody that knows president trump's
office he has guests frequently there it
is
it's just a joke they literally must
have gone in and taken out documents
they wanted or cover letters as it is
and put it about so that the public
believes that this is top secret
documents that were on his floor
it's ridiculous i can tell you
personally it's ridiculous i've never
seen that
oh
another edition another episode of
shitty legal takes
this is really [ __ ] stupid she is she
is like a [ __ ] you you
look i'm no lawyer okay i am no lawyer
however
oh however i would say that based on my
limited uh experience watching launch or
your twitter law degree yeah or just
watching law order you know
um i mean you're gonna learn a lot from
like criminal minds and yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but
this is the real you know i get the real
show from law and order but i can tell
you i'm no lawyer but what i've learned
from that show in other shows or movies
that i've watched is you don't typically
admit to a crime on national television
about what your client did let alone
admit that you were someone who did not
have clearance to see those part of it
yeah i was down there many times i seen
it all the time that's not how his
office normally is oh really
oh
okay what a stupid son of a [ __ ] what a
stupid son of a [ __ ] well you know the
the the the part that is crazy is when
sean hannity asked her you have
first-hand knowledge like sean you've
been in that [ __ ] room what are you
talking about don't do it don't you he's
like he's like were you also there give
me a break right he's like
you get the sticker that says i was
there right did you did you get to use
the cheeto dust stain sweat sex swing in
his office did you get to use that one
i'm serious he has first-hand knowledge
he's been
sean hannity has been in that room it is
likely folks that if he showed those
documents to kyle rittenhouse
bet your [ __ ] bottom dollar he showed
that [ __ ] to sean hannity yeah without a
doubt
and again the fact that anyone and this
is the this is the narrative they're
trying to push in in that night you know
i kind of listed out what the excuses
were of of things that they'd already
said of why he had the documents and i
was like i can't wait to see what next
excuse they come up with right
and sure enough the next excuse they
said was oh you know what
we're not even going to talk about how
he had the documents because yeah he had
the documents he had him in boxes and is
in his in his office but the real
problem here is that the fbi
strong in the basis
you can't go into donald trump's office
and take his classified documents that
he illegally stolen put them on the
floor that is illegal right that is
illegal and that is
you're going to tell me about all of you
guys all of these people
that represent trump
do not know what an investigation or a
crime scene looks like and they're like
hey we took photos and here's the
evidence of the like here's the photo
evidence
of these things that we're going to talk
about you're going to tell me that like
it's like you know [ __ ]
you see a dead body and there's chalk
and they're like that is not
right a dead body and that is not the
chalk that laid out that is not that is
not how he was originally they they
planted it like that you're going to
tell me that's what it is speaking of
trump's lawyers pictures of crime being
committed and evidence
you know a lot of people have been
talking about christina bob lately
because she's one of these boneheads
with these shitty legal takes
that really has herself in a pickle here
because it apparently she signed
she signed that yep he gave him all back
when he didn't yep she knew he didn't
she's in big trouble here
but a lot of people are getting
christina bob confused they keep saying
she is a former oan contributor
and that is true but that is not who she
is yeah she is more she was assigned to
that position to spread
propaganda for donald trump on oan
now tristan uh spells it out here
this is trump lawyer christina bob in
the willard hotel quote war room
the night of january 5th
2021 the day before the insurrection i
want to point out something
there's rudy giuliani
there's john eastman there's christina
bob and you don't see
because this
this guy whoever this guy's standing
here
steve bannon was also in this room
you talk about [ __ ] photographic
evidence of a crime and trump's lawyers
being involved in a crime lucky there
giuliani eastman
bob
trump's lawyers who are trying to
overthrow our government in the united
states you don't think that that's why
christina bob is doing the [ __ ]
she's doing because donald trump holds
the [ __ ] over her head
now the other thing i want to point out
is that she wasn't just an attorney who
was on oan
and she's not just an attorney who tried
to overthrow our government
that
that
christina bob
was part she was a government official
in the the homeland security
department of homeland security she was
an executive secretary in dhs
she had a high position this [ __ ]
idiot would know what classified
documents looked like she would know
what confidential information looks like
she would be trained as a dhs official
on how to handle and more importantly
how to not handle
confidential information especially when
it has to do with national defense
information which is what we're talking
about here
because they keep he keeps admitting the
crimes gabe but the real crime is this
[ __ ] was mishandling
national defense
information it doesn't matter about
declassified or when he did or if he
waved his big mac stained hands over the
documents it doesn't matter whether he
thinks they're his or whose they are
that doesn't or he can keep saying
presidential records act all he [ __ ]
wants right the main
the main crime here that they're gonna
other than obstruction now i mean we
know now clear it's obstruction of just
oh yeah but the main crime is that he
mishandled national defense information
he had it did so knowingly right
and did so
against
what his
lawyers and i use those quotes uh
loosely loosely on this because
i don't know how they got a law degree
based on you know i've been reading the
documents following along and also you
know reading on on what uh certain kind
of legal experts are just just being
like this is how you normally proc this
is how you normally submit this motion
this is what you normally talk about but
holy [ __ ] i read the one from last night
and it is
it is a lot of like
gibberish in the way that it is not it
is not formatted or is not making an
actual case formulator i even sent you
last night i was like they haven't i'm
three pages in and they haven't made a
case yet you mean you have to make a
case when you file a motion in court are
you kidding me crazy
this is ridiculous let's listen to
another couple lawyers opine on the
stupid-ass [ __ ]
the the picture that was taken
this is alan dershowitz
jeffrey epstein's right-hand man here
you know he's been crying a lot about
how oh no one likes me yeah no one
really likes someone who is best friends
with jeffrey epstein yeah and probably
did biles nasty [ __ ] with underage girls
dummy and then you have greta van
susteren here jesus christ this [ __ ]
idiot greta van chester and she's an
attorney too
she should know better but they don't
because they don't give a [ __ ] they
don't give a [ __ ] they want their orange
deity their their fascist dictator to
remain king let's listen
all right now return to that photograph
i don't know about you but if you i mean
when you buy an apartment in new york
you see how everything is staged it's
phony uh when you go online um this
photograph i unless these were stored
like this this is a staged photo
it
the is why they staged it is to take a
picture of the [ __ ] that was in the
carton as he puts it i'm telling you
they take that [ __ ] box right here
this box right here with the time
magazine frames in it it's in this
[ __ ] picture for a reason
i'm telling you that [ __ ] was in between
those frames and he told me didn't they
already i think it was yesterday i read
that they that they did comment on that
what i don't know i don't know i'm you
i'm i'm commenting on it for sure no i
know i'm i'm saying like when i was
reading about it was in between those
frames he had that [ __ ] tucked in
between those frames and he thought yeah
that's a good no one will find it there
no one will find it there you know this
is top secret [ __ ] gabe you can't just
be having this [ __ ] laying around
anywhere you got to tuck it in a box
somewhere in between [ __ ] that no one
will find yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] of course
they took it out because here's the
thing the picture either one a or
or
or maybe it's maybe it's yeah it says it
says they were mixed with the time
magazine covers and
mixed
he he had him tucked in between them so
that no one would see him
so that so certain people probably
people who were searching for him
wouldn't find him
and there was probably an informant so
like yeah he's got a box full of [ __ ]
time magazine covers that's where he's
got a bunch of those documents he stored
that's where he's got him and that's
when they went in they're like holy [ __ ]
they're right there
gabe i wonder do you think the fbi had
the wherewithal to take a picture of the
documents stuffed in between the time
magazine covers yeah before they took
them out and staged them for the
pictures so you could see what the hell
they were
yep
absolutely they do they
just it's you know this is gonna [ __ ]
all over their whole narrative when that
picture finally gets released because
we're gonna see that picture baby we're
going to see that i am [ __ ] i will
say this i'm surprised that uh they they
also haven't released that photo this
would be like a quick one-two punch boom
that's how we found it and here's us
setting up but of course people are
gonna oh they framed it it's on it they
set it up that way this was it looks
like okay hold on
again this is so that everyone can see
exactly what was [ __ ] packed in
between these these frames in this
in this box or elsewhere in his room on
his desk or whatever
having an excuse to be like oh it's
framed is [ __ ] right it doesn't give
you any standing but this is again one
more time when republicans
are doubling down on a very very dumb
take
we've seen it all over he took it home
with him because he was doing work he
took it home with him because he forgot
that he actually packed it was a chaotic
move day he took it home because oh
obama did it too he took it home because
they were declassified right a medley of
excuses that were all debunked and this
is another one that they try to push to
be like well that's not how they really
were i did have them and i did read them
but that's not how they were originally
and they staged in that way like it was
a [ __ ]
george soros set right it's the deep
state they're coming for me this isn't
actually mar-a-lago they took the photo
somewhere else and they planted it is
that a green screen behind them
documents is that what that carpet is
now listen
1a is probably definitely the picture 1a
because this is mark 2a the picture 1a
is definitely probably an upshot because
think about this if you're taking a
picture of documents in between frames
you would kind of like separate the
frames a little bit to show that this
document's in there you would put a 1a
you would put a ruler on there just like
they do here on floor you take a picture
of it that's one a and then like okay
now we have to show what the hell these
documents are actually in this box right
so they take them out lay them on the
floor they're like oh my god they lay
them on the floor they're like okay this
is 2a this is the [ __ ] that one a is
this where we found them 2a is actually
what they are yeah and three three a
might i would imagine that three four a
five a six a a so on are more up-close
shots of this of what it actually is
well because when you do your when you
do your evidence inventory you have to
be like okay cool this collection
is photographed here and this is what
you can you this is what in the list is
there so you'll have the photographs and
then you'll have the things because also
i don't know how you handle evidence
like this for especially for people who
need to have clearance like it's
probably stored somewhere very secure
and even those documents might have to
be returned
and you know and marked for for further
kind of uh you know uh looking into
but they probably have photos of those
things on record i would imagine
to say like all right here all the
documents
here all the documents in this order
here's the list so on and so forth and
if we need to find them we go to this
location to actually read them or
whatever right well then the other thing
too is it's not hard to disseminate this
from this picture there's a reason why
that box with the time magazine frames
is in the shot that's the reason why
they set them on the floor right there
running around trying to find a spot on
the floor to put them the reason why
they put them on the floor right there
is because they came right out of that
box onto the floor to take a picture
because they wanted the picture of them
in the box and picture of them out of
the box what the hell the words it it's
not hard to put this together yeah and
really honestly if
these [ __ ] idiots because here's the
thing
he's going to file motion the judge is
going to make her decision today on this
stupid special master thing
trump is definitely going to fire file a
bunch of more stupid ass motions in
court within written in crown and the
department of justice is gonna have the
ability to pile on more [ __ ] and i would
imagine they're just waiting laying in
wait for the picture that is going to
prove that yes we did take them out of
the box because you had them in the box
between the frames you took that picture
too and and it's going to [ __ ] all over
this narrative that somehow
if you if you take them out of the the
the box that's evidence and you take
pictures of the evidence so that you can
prove in court what was in there yep
then that's i think i'm i'm gonna be
very very curious of
maybe maybe
i'm just trying to imagine how a
criminal would defend another criminal
uh
all right so let's say that they go back
and forth and doj's like okay fine look
you're claiming you are claiming that we
did this here is the original photo 1a
and 1a might have a hand in there to
kind of separate the frames or whatever
there might have to be some things
covered up depending on how the folders
and papers are exposed
but they're going to release that photo
right let's imagine that they do pro
possibly will
the instant reaction won't be like oh
[ __ ] this is not good this goes against
what we said the next thing they're
gonna say is
and double down on
they mishandled
the evidence
and they they manipulate they took it
out they put it they might they might
have mixed things in so now it's not
only like well there was actual evidence
there there were actual bad things that
he had that were there now it's going to
be like
well yes okay they were there
but they took them out of the box so
they mishandled them so how do we know
that other people's fingerprints aren't
on these documents and they're gonna say
well that's not how you normally handle
those things you you take a photo and
you log it and then you you don't you
don't mix up the other evidence with
stuff how do we know they didn't put new
stuff in the existing bad evidence
i guarantee that's probably where their
argument goes is they took it out of the
box
and then they could have
probably mixed in new evidence
with the already
evidence that's there
she ha makes a really really good point
here that carpet should earn you 10
years in the pen i am an agreeance this
garbage is an absolute crime against
humanity
oh my god
yeah sorry i saw well yes i agree this
is someone that you would this is a
crime against humanity this is a faux
pas in many ways
it is like you said at motel 6. i was
going to show the rest of this clip but
i don't even want to hear dershowitz
anymore do you want to watch do you want
to you want to see a dead body yeah yeah
buddy i got a dead body for you here
um his name is brian kemp yeah the
governor of georgia he absolutely gets
his [ __ ] ass
and stuffed in a trash can here
by stacey abrams this is one of the best
[ __ ] clips for democracy that you
will ever see you should spread it
around everywhere stacey abrams
tate has no [ __ ] and takes no goddamn
hostages here she absolutely chops his
[ __ ] head off watch this my question
is why are you encouraging people to
break the law for you in this election
mr kemp you are very aware that i know
the laws of georgia when it comes to
voting in fact i am one of the foremost
experts in the state on expansion of
voting rights and i have never in my
life i love i love how she doesn't even
glance over that mother she's like you
are not worth my time i can see you out
of my [ __ ] peripheral right now and i
don't give a [ __ ] because here's the
thing i'm not talking to you
i'm making my case to the georgia people
oh yeah i she just sticks
sticks her foot so far up his ass and
just breaks it off here yeah this is
incredible it gets way better it just
gets i mean it's like a minute and 12
seconds but it gets better and better
and better watch this
ask for anyone who is not legally
eligible to vote to be able to cast a
ballot what i've asked for is that you
allow those who are legally eligible to
vote to allow them to cast their ballot
and in fact we took you to court in 2016
and a federal judge said that you
illegally canceled 34 000 registrations
you use the exact same system the exact
match system that is under dispute right
now now i realize that in the next
response you're going to say that it's a
function of my organization because your
tendency is to blame everyone else for
the mistakes that you make my
responsibility as a leader is to see a
problem and try to solve it when i saw
that we had eight hundred thousand
unregistered people of color in the
state of georgia i started an
organization that has reached into every
county and increased those registrations
when i saw the people being unlawfully
denied the right to vote i work to make
certain that we held you accountable and
as the next governor of georgia i will
continue to do my job to make certain
that every legally eligible vote that
gets cast gets counted
delicious
[ __ ] delicious oh my god so good
absolutely just look i know you're gonna
i know what you're gonna say and you
should shut your [ __ ] mouth right now
because this is why you're wrong
and i'm not again i'm not even gonna
look at you [ __ ] not even
this is more of a reason what i'm saying
lean into democracy she totally 100
gives him the big middle finger of
democracy here
and basically takes brian kemp's ability
away from him
to even rebut this right like she
strategically she knew exactly what he
was going to say yeah if you bring it up
if you bring it i mean like it is a
debate tactic if you bring it up first
and you address it
and you would especially address what
their their argument is going to be
then it deflates anything that they have
then they're like well
i mean
why are you so mean
you know
what you think brian kemp would go yeah
i guarantee you social impose that why
are people why should i say brian kemp
is another whiny little baby who the
only win the only way he knows how to
win is look steal votes and cancel
registration look at him look at this
guy
look at this guy
what what more look at him
he's really wanting her attention dire
he's he's
really wants her to turn and she knows
that that's why she's like [ __ ] you
ain't giving you you know give me one
goddamn i just adds fuel fuel she's like
[ __ ] you man
i don't have to give you the time of day
because you don't deserve it right up
your ass but brian kemp here ryan gabe
here is in a lot of trouble here and the
reason why
is because not only did stacey abrams
totally destroy
the entire argument that brian kemp has
for you to vote for him
she did it in a way that gives power to
the people yeah like it's your power use
it use it it's then that is what we keep
saying here is lean into democracy don't
be scared of it tonight we're gonna see
that with joe biden i think yeah now i
don't know if joe biden can really
um stick the ice cream cone up uh
manga's ass and break it off like steve
jaber did here with the ballot straight
up brian yeah i think there's a certain
level of etiquette he has to abide by
right but here's the thing is i think i
think what democrats are doing now with
their messaging is inviting the entirety
of the country not just people who
identify as democrats but people who
don't want these fascists telling them
what the [ __ ] to do
who they can marry who they can love who
they can [ __ ] how they can [ __ ] them
what to read what you can't read what
religion you can have what religion you
can't have
they're tired of this stuff they're
absolutely sick of it
and like i was saying in the first
section of the podcast
there are folks out there who are gonna
go vote who don't know what a democrat
is they have no clue what a republican
is they don't know that's okay they
still get to vote they still have the
right yeah but we have to tell them as a
democracy we have to get the messaging
out there that hey
you may not know what a republican is
but here's what they are they wanted to
you know the people taking your [ __ ]
away from you like your medical
procedures to save your life like the
book fairs down in georgia they want to
they want to take the ability for your
neighbor to be married to the person
they love those things that they want to
take away those are the republicans go
vote against it yeah go vote for the
pro-democracy candidate and that
candidate does not have an r next to
their name because there's only one
party right now that is pro-democracy
it's pro-freedom pro-liberty pro-rights
and that's the democrats and that's all
you need to know that is all you need to
know and let me tell you something
americans vote against [ __ ] and they are
going to vote against the party that is
trying to take their liberty and their
rights away right you as a citizen as a
pro-democracy person
have to spread that message and engage
in your democracy and lean into it lean
into it the way that stacey abram does
so greatly oh my god whatever i mean i
mean she is oh my [ __ ] wicked smart
she's very good at what she does and she
comes in with razor sharp precision on
how to [ __ ] like a surgeon she cuts
around it's like all right we're going
to remove this [ __ ] fat because this
is some [ __ ]
right like the ability that she's able
to cut around what she knows he will
argue and what she knows he will try to
use as some sort of uh point against her
she addresses it right out of the gate
which means it removes any ability for
him to address it because there's
nothing more to add to it right just
because well i didn't say well that's
not how it is it's like you have nothing
left
and so and to the point of of democrats
dem you know democrats deliver right
republicans destroy when it comes to
things like if you think hey i should
have health care i should have the
ability to go study wherever i want or i
should have the ability to not be
uh in in a crazy amount of debt if i
decide to go get a degree to advance my
my way of living to earn a higher wage
or you know i feel like i should have
these other rights
republicans are the ones who are taking
away those things republicans are the
ones who are arguing that you don't
deserve them
you haven't earned them you're not rich
you're not white you're not powerful you
don't have influence you don't get those
things that you don't
you know republicans try to try to paint
this picture that these things like
healthcare education just your own
bodily autonomy
gun reform yeah gun reform and making
making the actual area that you live in
safe and not have to worry about someone
just you know shooting it up because
they're able to get a a firearm at the
age of 18. these are things that aren't
radical these are things that are just
oh i'm a human and i actually have these
wants and desires to be like i want
these i want the ability to have access
to these things i want to have my own
choice but republicans again and again
and again and again
will strip them from you will take them
from you and tell you you actually don't
know what you want and we know what you
want so we're going to make the choice
and decision for you
and you just got to sit there and take
it and i think now we're seeing you know
especially in the last couple months
we're seeing abide and deliver on a lot
of these things that will help the
everyday american person
they're now seeing like oh my okay this
is really [ __ ] up [ __ ] that they've
been doing and we've kind of hit you
know a boiling point and we're gonna see
it in the midterms well here here is a
prime example of what you're talking
about here because bet o'rourke has got
uh greg abbott on his heels here and he
has to answer
and i want to point something out here
if you see these people in the
background holding the signs doesn't it
look like someone's holding them at
gunpoint to do this i mean it seems like
they're uncomfortable like they don't
want to be there like you know i just
hire them craigslist right maybe a
facebook marketplace if they don't seem
excited at all but listen how greg
abbott
defends
defends
three years worth of age
on making sure someone doesn't get
weapons of war we're not talking about
banning weapons of war we're just
talking about being three years older to
buy one yeah and beto has got him in
this position because beto was going
around the state talking to the
community members and that's what
they're telling him is like hey we are
fine with you have to be 21 to buy these
[ __ ] and beto's like i agree
with you
he actually probably would go further
but he's like i i agree with you on that
because he's going around talking to
people in the community about their
community and here this guy is hiring
these [ __ ] craigslisters to hold this
sign up being held hostage and he's he's
talking about how the nra won't let him
change the age limit listen very much
there have been three court rulings uh
since matt
that have made it clear that it is
unconstitutional
to ban someone between the ages of 18
and 20. that's [ __ ] yeah that is
absolutely that is not that is not a
[ __ ] lie and that's that's the
difference is greg abbott is making
excuses why he can't protect texans and
beto is going out there telling them hey
we can find solutions to help protect
you and your family that's the biggest
[ __ ] difference yeah is hey beto's
like hey we can use democracy for us all
to live in a better spot and greg
abbott's like nope democracy sucks i'm
telling you what you got to do the nra's
telling you what you got to do i'm going
to lie to you if i have to to get you to
do what we want you to do and that well
also he's got to continue line because
they make sure that the you know
continues to get nra
uh
uh donations right from lobbyists he
because the the fact that he's able to
well i spoke to a few groups and they
said it was illegal no it's not it's not
you can change the law and say i mean
look the law the
you know we've changed laws when
drinking age driving age right these are
all laws that had an age or didn't have
an age and then we incorporated an age
and they're like okay great
we did that there wasn't a group that
was like oh you can't change the age of
a driver you can't change the age for
you know alcohol or or or
you know smoking
or or
cannabis or whatever it might be like
the the argument that you can't change
an already existing age requirement
is 100 [ __ ] and you just have to
look at everything that was changed
before that it's ridiculous well the
other thing too
here is that that if you want to find
out if something's constitutional or not
you you set it in a law and
and the courts and people will decide
our laws will decide we have checks and
balances in this country we'll decide if
it's unconstitutional that's one of the
problems that we have with our supreme
court is they're bought and paid for and
they're bought and paid for to take your
rights away from you and say ah it's not
it's not constitutional we can take it
we can take your rights away if we want
and that's what we have to change that's
what we have to change but listen to the
more of the dribble from from captain
wheels here
from being able to buy an ar that came
out of the federal court of appeals and
then there was a supreme court decision
uh that was in line that would have
upheld it and then after that
lies lies texas struck down the texas
law
that banned people between the ages of
18 and 20 for buying a handgun so it's
clear that the gun control law that they
are seeking and uvalding as much as they
may want it it has already been ruled to
be unconstitutional so we can't i'm not
going to protect children and and
families because i'm weak
as much as they may want the the parents
and the families who have experienced
this insanely traumatic event
and an insanely incompetent
police force
who who just stood by did nothing right
they went to the hallway and they're
like oh can't do anything you know held
parents back or willing to go in and
sacrifice their own lives to save their
own child their own children right you
had cops who went in there before anyone
else to make sure their kids were safe
these are the things when he brings up
oh just by what they want to do when you
value no [ __ ] that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that because what he's saying is
not only again
uh
did the cops do nothing
did he not visit any of the funerals for
those victims he doesn't care he will do
whatever he can to continue to get
donations
and other money from lobbyists from the
nra and the nra says here are your
talking points this is what you have to
say and he's been caught in several lies
along the way of what he knew what he
didn't know uh uh right after uvalde
but this excuse of
it's on it's unconstitutional they can't
do that is [ __ ] it is absolute
[ __ ] it's just a way for him to not
be held accountable right to those
families and that's and that's not the
only thing too right like just yesterday
i think it was announced that 12 million
dollars had been wasted
on sending people outside of the state
of texas right well i mean we're talking
about that on the bus yeah he's he's
he's continued with his human
trafficking his action human trafficking
uh there's no question about that
there's one last clip i want to show
here um
i said earlier that
we invite trumpers to come here we want
them to come here because i actually
think i can convince them that
liberalism is actually the strength in
this country not the weakness fascism is
weak
not not not liberalism liberalism is
tough i mean you have to compromise you
have to find ways not to get your
community in one spot to progress to be
actually
right you have to you have to think
about these things you have to actually
do things for other human beings
but uh walter um posted this video
walter's a friend of the show he posted
this video this morning he's had a some
kind of i don't know trump event or
something it's uh clay clark's reopening
america tour or some [ __ ] um
but he's talking to these these trumpers
now this guy here has a trump hat on and
if you notice he's got a vest here with
the uh back the blue flag
but uh walter is trying to explain
uh police reform to these people
by talking about the fbi he al they
almost get there he almost gets them
there well that's all we always have
always right fbi raid
on donald trump's mar-a-lago estate
absolutely disgusting
i'm really worried about this
weaponization of law enforcement exactly
you have these people they have a gun
and a badge no accountability i'm
worried that like they're going to come
to my house in the middle of the night
while i'm sleeping no knock warrant and
just shoot me exactly they've got a
patches they've got guns
come to your house they always walk
straight into this game they're like yep
yep yep no totally yeah totally like
like brianna taylor heard of her no no
no not her not her she was a criminal or
you know whatever they're gonna say like
she was black that's what they mean but
here here when they're talking about
themselves and they're talking about
white people and they're talking about
the fbi and their deity trump and the
fbi of course they want to get rid of
police officers of course they do i mean
hypocrisy is is oozing here let's listen
to this guy who has it by the way he has
a shirt on that says trump won
and below that it says infowars.com i'm
sure this guy is just a wealth a wealth
of [ __ ] he's done his research he
knows what he's talking about he is the
legal expert of his community oh so i
just want to key that up let's listen to
what questions walter ask him here hold
the night and shoot you while you're
sleeping
and you know they have what qualified
immunity right they have qualified
immunity
right the fbi or the irs does something
who investigates so they investigate
themselves exactly no
no they're they're getting full control
we investigated ourselves and we found
that no wrongdoing it's full gestapo
they can just come to your house and
shoot you
and they're not subject to civilian law
right you imagine like an irs agent
coming into your house with the no knock
warrant while you're sleeping and
shooting you exactly bobert just said
defund the fbi you can't just reform
them just abolish them abolish abolish
you cannot create a law enforcement
agency that has all the rights in the
world okay it takes all your
constitutional rights away
i think it depends
there are a lot of bad cops out there
too i'm not anti-cop
i support the good guys
but i mean every law enforcement agency
in america is
you know they've got corruption in them
okay so i want to point out here um the
masterful job that walter does to un to
undo these people uh and again he put
eve up there on words he got so close
they they run almost face first into it
oh yeah then he said but i wanna i wanna
say
these people vote
i don't know if you um are okay with
that or not but the only way the only
way to make sure
is to go
engage in your democracy yourself not
just you vote i mean you got to do that
but you have to get more people to vote
you have to do this you have to support
pro-democracy
candidates you have to support the
pro-democracy party and tonight tonight
the president united states i think is
going to lay that out say we are the we
are the party of democracy
they are the party of fascism they are
the party of autocracy they want to take
your rights and your liberty away we as
the people who want to have the soul of
the nation be equity equality liberty
rights and freedom we are the
pro-democracy party i think that's what
he's going to lay out tonight join us
tonight on the midas touch podcast it is
a special edition me and gable guest
co-host with them
um we are going to be on the midas touch
network the link is in the description
down below so go down below hit the link
for tonight's speech of joe biden the
midas touch podcast will carry it live
tonight at the regular time
7 eastern is when we will start our
coverage we'll play play the president's
speech and then talk afterwards with the
mizellas brothers on a special edition
of the midas touch podcast do not miss
it tonight you must be there you need to
see this it is going to be a hell a hell
of a statement from the president united
states it's going to probably be
historic especially with the election
that we are coming into and all you
pro-democracy people who are going to
come out in rovember as they say it
might as touch rovember and you are
going to save our democracy so support
pro-democracy speech support the
pro-democracy party be pro-democracy
engage in your ballot
and join us here every single weekday
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
and twitch don't forget to subscribe
while you're here before you go over and
set your reminder for biden's speech
tonight also follow us on twitter at
tony michael's pod tomorrow is bonehead
of the week oh yeah the poll is going up
today and we got a shitload of boneheads
to pick
voting for bone end of the week on
twitter or on youtube also download
every single episode of the tony
michaels podcast on youtube or excuse me
now it's spotify apple google wherever
you get your your podcast in audio form
also give us a great review while you're
there subscribe
gabe until tomorrow actually until
tonight on the minds
until tonight seven eastern biden speech
on the midas touch podcast but until
tomorrow here on the tony michaels
podcast same time
same place noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific youtube twitter twitch and
simulcasting from the midas touch
facebook page
surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking